[ __ ] you all the people on reddit
we're working on it okay we're doing
things like
also guys we are doing we're not just in
autopilot
that's not us have you ever known that
to be us no
just a coast no
no we're gonna we're we're gonna be
we're gonna beat joe rogan
yeah we're not enough i'm not we're not
an autopilot [ __ ] we still do the
dishes
yeah you generally you know do you know
how many other people that
that get to this level and they just
stop cleaning their own house we still
clean our own house and you do
damn damn damn
one of the best one of the best
that's not fair though that's not fair
who's who's who who's your who's your
person
i'm gonna call him up and and buy him
out no you need to be humbled man
no dude need to bring you back down to
zero dude if there's
ever a place if there's ever
something to spend money on dude
i'm telling you it's the shut the [ __ ]
up right now it's about
i'm just what do you want me to do why
you want me to lie
and just yeah
if there's ever something to spend money
on uh there's a good
naval tweet he says spend money to save
time
don't spend time to save money yeah
no of course but you know some things
you got to do
to stay humble like you got you got to
fold your own clothes
yeah yeah that's why i make alina fold
all my clothes so you know
she stays humble
she's gonna come running in here what
the [ __ ] did you say
yeah fold that hold that spare shirts
just
dirty underneath you in the face yeah
fold that too
also coming out with socks in my face
fold those up
here's some stinky ones guys you heard
from me first okay this remember
this applies to any kind of couple all
right you just have to be the one to do
it first
make the other person do the laundry to
keep them humble
yeah it doesn't you know you could be
the
relationship babe i'm just trying to
keep you humble
yeah i'm just trying babe i'm trying to
this is a lesson
gaslighting to the fullest you've become
a little bit
cocky i just think that your behavior is
a little bit odd i just
you know i think you should just maybe
you should fold the laundry at this
remind yourself where you came from yeah
yeah
get in touch with the things that you
know your mom did to take care of you
right you little [ __ ]
jesus christ now listen i do do
the dishes whenever i cook i do the
dishes right afterwards
okay and i cook a lot yeah you are
cooking a lot i'm just saying that
i have i there i don't mind having a
little help once in a while
you know not yet no a little hell once
in a while is a-okay
yeah and by the way the quote the naval
quote i'm saying that's if
if you have money if you have the
resources to do that
i think it's i think one of the best
things the ways to spend money is on
experiences
and uh saving yourself time because time
is
the ultimate currency that's the one
that matters the most
yeah in life because it's you know
we don't have a lot of it so yeah this
is exactly
what i tell of the team of developers
who are creating the
ai version of me so i never have to work
again
it's what's exactly what i tell them
it's important to spend money to save
time you know what i mean no but that's
i like working though
oh you know what i'm saying wait you
just kind of still rolling
sorry we're back they don't what were we
talking about they don't they don't want
me to record man what happened those are
the people from reddit
they heard me talking [ __ ] they wouldn't
take his internet out
i'm gonna take his internet out
so your power went out and now your
internet just went out yeah
now they're both back what the heck's
going on over there dude
homeless guy man took the internet with
him big ass
dick big ass dad bad guy stack yeah
this [ __ ] homeless guy came through a
big-ass dick
bro this guy had a big ass stick to
all the power man it was crazy
[Laughter]
this is jesse from the fast and furious
yeah man
this guy came through the big ass dick
took the whole
power down big rip though
is he oh is that not the main guy is
that not what
it's not paul oh it's not who paul
ryan's that's brian spillner okay
my bad jesse is like
jesse's dom's right hand man dude
you know you don't need bro look up why
can't i ever why can i not remember what
he looks like
bruh that's like one of the best sounds
like he's surf so
yeah no he's like he's just a oc
kid with a trembly ass voice [ __ ]
dude i got pitted big ass
tube i was deep in that tube dude
my fat dick
yeah i was like in it too
surfing is kind of like the circle of
life man like
how did you get here you came through a
big ass
tube yeah dude and that's the same thing
i'm just like a sperm
still riding his wave full just swimming
through the tube
trying to make it out into the world
my big ass day [ __ ]
big ass [ __ ] dick in the tube full
well you saw a guy paddle boarding and
he's like backspace too you're about to
get pissed off like don't [ __ ]
paddleboard and he just kind of like
floats around his
massive hanger oh yeah like a third leg
hanging like a just a tree trunk hanging
out from your [ __ ]
oh when people get a new surfboard they
say
they say i got a new stick it's my new
stick
right right we got to make a surfboard
brand called
knight nice stick ah nice stick
nice stick or a big big stick no that
one doesn't really
um we dude we laugh so [ __ ] hard
every time in call of duty whenever
the characters get in the helicopter
they go i can take this stick
i can take the stick i can take the
stick
now get out again i'll get back in get
out again and get back in
i can take the stick get back out and
get back in please i can take this stick
no i can take the stick you're just you
just download a different dlc to hear
that line in different voices
i can take this stick yeah this girl's
super hot wait listen to her get in the
helicopter
i can take this stick
you